Welcome to our first Black History
Month event celebration. Can we give it up
for yourselves for coming, for Black Creek, for being here, for it
being Black History Month?
My name is Dr. Akeem Stewart. I'm the provincial lead for Black Health and Wellness
for the Black Health Committee of the Alliance for Healthier Communities.
We gotta remember one thing, and Trevor Noah said it, that the
compromise or the sacrifice of advancement of a metropolitan state is
community. And we come from community, and together, that's how everything is
made, and it's the foundation, the solidity of what, who we are, we
could find it. As a culture, we've shared many stories.
We've shared many experiences to keep us building
up.
I was so excited. After all the
snows and everything, one has been indoors for a
quite a long time. I was so excited that this was
coming up because we always look forward to Black Creek
events. Their events are so enjoyable, and of course,
the food.
We always enjoy the food.
My name is Noella Charles. I'm the CEO and manager of Ella
Charles Cuisine. One of the things we do is w- I teach culinary
classes right across the city. After school programs, I was
teaching for quite a while at Front Lines Youth who are out
of school. W- I would say we do everything, but my specialty would be
Caribbean. My background, I was born in Saint Lucia, but
raised in Ottawa by my grandmother, so I'm really
carrying over what she taught me.
The funds we get from Black Creek u- that will go towards any
meats, additional meat we need, containers, because it's takeout right
now. Without them, we wouldn't be able to do it on such a large
scale. So what we get from them, we try to use, like meats, and
milk, potatoes, stuff like that. We use what we can.
Mm-hmm.
And what we need, we use the money from Black Creek to buy,
especially meat. Meat is so expensive now.
It's ridiculous. But yeah, it goes a long
way.
I just want to thank Black Creek Community Health Center for all they have done for
this community, even myself, because they had gave me a
platform. They highlight me, and they gave me a platform. I just want to thank Dr.
Mar, you know, to show me that, you know, "Come on in, girl, you
can do it." Cheryl, Josie, you know, they are great
people. Working here at Black Creek is one of the most
achievement I ever had in my life. I've worked in the school
before. I've been in the church. I've lived in my community, but Black Creek
is a place that give you a sense of belong.
And as I said, Black Creek is the beacon of hope for our community, so I will
always grateful for Black Creek Community Health
Center.
As a people, as humans, we're not supposed to be in isolation.
So when you can be together with those who understand you without you saying a
word, it brings out another side of you that is m- that promotes a better
sense of
wellness.
Happy
Black History Month.